Victoria is with us in Austin Texas hi
Victoria how are you hey I'm doing I'm
doing okay how are you better than I
deserve what's up I'm calling because
I'm kind of in a tricky situation I've
been a stay-at-home mom for the past two
years I'm relatively young I'm 23 and I
don't have any kind of schooling my
husband's informed me that we're going
to be getting divorced pretty soon and I
don't have much of a financial savings
for myself to move on and get a place on
my own or do anything I don't have
family to help me out so I wanted to
know what would you recommend for me to
do during this time do I go do I do
school full-time and work I mean I
really don't know where to begin I know
work is involved but I don't want to be
stuck in a minimum paying job my
youngest is two I have a five-year-old a
two-year-old
how long have you guys been married
we've been married about five years and
when did he inform you of his decision
it was last week but it's been several
months leading up to this so it's um you
know the legality of it's going to
happen relatively soon have you seen an
attorney no I have not
you need to today you start making
arrangements on that today because the
only thing that the only information
you've got about this situation is
information he has given you and it
might not be accurate um probably isn't
so what is his income his income is
50,000
and y'all I have any money nope neither
one of you no you sure yeah okay and are
you living in a rental yes
and all right well you need to see an
attorney because you need to at least
find out what your child support and
potential alimony looks like in this
situation and then that'll help you have
some information to try to figure out
what your next steps are right now
you're dealing with some fear and some
heartbreak and so it's a little
difficult to dream positively and say
goodness I could be anything I want to
be when I'm 33 10 years from now this is
gonna be a sucky memory and I'm gonna be
a rock star doing XYZ it's a little hard
to think like that right now but that's
that's your next step okay is to start
thinking about gosh when I'm 33 or when
I'm 43 and I'm making $150,000 a year
what am I gonna be doing what is it I
can do if I because I can do anything I
wanted to I'm only 23 I got the whole
life anomie there's a lot of cool stuff
I can do and make this horrible mess
look like a bad memory because that
should become what it is and then once
you say I want to be one of those when
I'm 33 43 one of those I don't care what
one of those is you see what I'm saying
it's kind of the whole question you ask
your little kid your ask your
five-year-old what do you want to be
when you grow up right of course they
always say a cowboy or a fireman or
whatever right but you're you know I
don't know what you want to do but you
say that's what I want to do then you
can decide if going to school is one of
the things necessary to become one of
those things for instance if you were
going to be a residential real estate
agents you would not need to go get a
four-year degree you could pass your
license and take the pre-licensing
courses and enter that field I'm not
suggesting that I'm just giving an
example of a thing where I know lots of
ladies who make you know 100 200 300
thousand dollars a year doing that as an
example but and and so if you had just
automatically gone off to school and
then decide you want to do that you
would have wasted the time and the money
on the school because you would have
gone the wrong direction so let's figure
out where you're going and then what are
the steps to get there and how do we
survive while we're taking those steps
at our feed to kids on child support pay
rent work and
get my degree in X or Y or Z or take my
classes in a or B or C and your but
you're just right now
trying to just digest this pain in this
fear is that right hmm yeah more yeah I
think that's more such digesting the
sphere and knowing what my future is
going to look like the short term yeah
it's kind of worried about eating yeah
yeah are you in a good church no we I
actually just I just moved here about
four months ago and I were yet to find a
place out in Austin in Austin Texas no
from where did you move Oh some from
Miami okay is that where family is yeah
what about returning I don't think
that's going to be something that I can
do I'd have to talk to an attorney and
see if I'm able to yeah I think you're
23 and you have two little kids and he's
the one causing this I think he's the
one that's going to have a visitation
problem not you you need to be what it's
good for you and these kids and yeah you
need to talk to an attorney
you sure do does he say that's one of
those issues where he's telling you what
something is that might not be true or
so I find out what your options are but
I want to get you in an area where some
people can get their arms around you and
help you whether it's your local church
or family or both those kinds of things
but you're you know you're in a strange
city stuck out here in the middle of
nowhere so to speak not that Austin is
the middle of nowhere but I mean for you
it is and you may need to return to some
areas of comfort and the courts may very
well let you do that they may may vary
way he's the one decided he's the one
pushing this and so you know it's gonna
cost him I'm gonna make him pay on some
fronts yeah that that's where I am so
I'm sorry you're facing this I wish I
could be more help directly but I want
you to get together get an attorney and
once you get together a long term plan
and that one
form your short-term decisions on
survival and on steps to take to have
the great long term dream life this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]